[Applause]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley
[Music]
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is
r u gabbage the show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and fun if they
grew up classy
or if they're a big old piece of [ __ ]
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful it's a sunday evening here
in new york city
everything has calmed down there's a
great energy in the air it's been nice
and warm
uh we got a beautiful week coming up
ahead and we thought it'd be a nice
opportunity to do a little
family time yeah the old family episode
just me and kippy kevin james ryan
truth be told we're still working out
some audio video issues
i just stroked out right there yeah uh
big shout out to our
to our producer our partner our comrade
toby mcmullen
who's over there working the old ones
and twos set the whole thing up uh we
love you buddy
smoking his jewel like a [ __ ] like
some new age [ __ ] millennial over
there you kids at those jewels man
i don't know i'm watching you gang my
co-host is sitting across the table from
me
uh he uh when he was a kid
he liked his eggs dippy mm-hmm okay he
liked his peanut butter
skippy yeah when he gets a couple ipas
in him he gets a little
trippy give it up for the one the only
the [ __ ] of ceremonies the chairman
of the board his name's on the lease
gang
insurance still not covered shout out to
kelly sue huh
that's my agent really something like
that yeah gang kevin james ryan
everybody look at him he's here he's in
the flesh he's [ __ ] two feet away
from you look at him the godfather
hey what's up guys happy to be here as
always please make sure you rate review
subscribe on itunes yes yes
those numbers are through the [ __ ]
roof thank you so much
please make sure you subscribe on
youtube as well those numbers are
[ __ ]
through the [ __ ] roof and then the
big one baby
www.patreon.com
are you garbage um guys and listen to we
do these
episodes because we get hundreds
of [ __ ] questions that people write
in they message us email dm you know
comment on facebook
also check out the facebook group and
stuff like that yeah those guys are
awesome
um but we can't get to all of them
there's just too many
um so what we're doing is when you join
the patreon we're gonna
automatically you know read your
question if you submit one if you don't
have to i mean most of you did also
shout out
we're almost at by this time this comes
out we'll probably be at our first
benchmark
on patreon which is 250 which we do the
mtv cribs of the foley household
want to discuss that with you yeah go
ahead i think that's getting a little
bit of pushback
from mr and mrs it's happening 100 of
course it's [ __ ] happening we got 250
people on the
chomping at the bit for it i'll do it
i'll [ __ ] i'll send
those bozos out for a steak dinner and
go in there with [ __ ] t-money and
[ __ ] shoot that [ __ ] my mom was
talking about a little cash
you know what i mean i'm sure she has
some sort of rental they know yeah they
know
[ __ ] you know that sopranos house
they paid those people
patty and terry got to get their [ __ ]
beaks a little bit
you guys are far from the sopranos house
okay
maybe the pool house at the same time
they never hung out in there i don't
know what the problem was i've been
hanging out in the pool house all the
time on the sopranos
yeah uh but guys thank you so much so
that's what we're gonna do we have a
[ __ ] ton of
super super good um questions from the
patreons uh and we're gonna [ __ ]
get into it now all right so if you want
to get a question on the air sign up for
patreon
right yes patreon.com right when you
sign up we'll you know we're going to
read through your questions we're going
to get as many as we can today but i
mean there's you know hundreds to get
through so we're going to we're going to
be cranking them out you know every uh
week or so
and uh get into it you know what i mean
why do you got a weird [ __ ] and grin on
your face i don't like it
i'm just thinking about the conversation
i had with my mother yesterday oh she's
not gonna like me in there [ __ ] on
her [ __ ] house
okay okay i'm gonna get our pack of ball
balls and send her down the block well i
told him they gotta they gotta hit the
[ __ ] skids for a little while
i don't know we're gonna i don't know
we're gonna do it the old man we're
gonna do with igor we got him he's got
that
he's in that space chair we gotta get
him out of that oh i'm definitely
[ __ ] pulling my putt in that thing
turning the heater on on that and
[ __ ] going to town on myself man i do
i don't care what kind of [ __ ]
sectional you got in your house this
that dude a good recline good
dirty trashy recliner that like there's
like cheetos and like
down in the armrest and stuff that have
just been like worn in that like your
dad or your uncle has just been [ __ ]
farting and watching [ __ ] football in
for [ __ ] the last 30 years
you getting one of those things when you
were a kid [ __ ]
yeah like we had a lazy boy that the dog
commit like [ __ ]
committed suicide no he took he just
like what do they call that when you
like steal the people
they stop you when a police stops you
and goes get out they
crander or what's the word what is it
no they take something for this stop and
frisk what are you talking about no when
like
in like the movies where they're like
i'm a police commandeer they commented
my dog commandeered the lazy boy and
[ __ ] took that thing over
dude you couldn't sit on it without him
getting all [ __ ] if a cop ever did
that [ __ ] would you give me your car i
mean get the [ __ ] out of here yeah
i got no gas [ __ ] easy passes after
me
i can't be doing maybe if maybe if we
can talk about you clearing some [ __ ]
picky tickets they never they'd ever say
that in the movie
you get in there's [ __ ] you [ __ ] got
a quarter tank yeah
chasing a helicopter here
yeah i'm like i've been low on oil for
three weeks i'm like take it easy on the
[ __ ]
ain't gonna get far in that donut
officer but go ahead
by the way real trash bag move first of
all after we do
my house we're going to do my car is it
going to be the next benchmark
dude that thing is this thing is a real
piece of [ __ ] you it almost looks like
it might be it's like you know like a
james bond car made to look like a piece
it looks so cartoonishly shitty like you
have the rust around the back
and here's the real thing this thing's a
real [ __ ] box i parked my whip on the
same street that you parked on it
because sunday in new york city you got
free parking park anywhere it's [ __ ]
fantastic because we've been getting
crushed
coming into the city where the studio is
there's no parking anywhere yeah by the
way i'll be turning in my receipts at
the end of the month yeah
i don't know if a jew works it's gonna
be it's gonna be coming out of your
paycheck too big man
i don't know if it's you or susie who
whoever you got handling the [ __ ]
numbers
but uh i walk by your car
and you still have your parking garage
that was from this morning yeah yeah
that's i saw it i was like whatever
let people know you got a little money
yeah you know i'm [ __ ] valet in this
thing you know what i mean i'm dropping
it off up front
tossing the keys i took a nice pick of
that i'll post it your [ __ ]
trash bag [ __ ] car i looked inside a
couple unmentionables in there oh yeah
for sure well i've been living in it i
was a [ __ ] i was driving i was in
mohegan sun driving up and back and
forth to [ __ ] connecticut and doing
[ __ ] late night mickey d's to stay up
and [ __ ] like that
oh yeah kippy's got the ronies um shut
up
super spreader event um all right so
this is actually this plays into it this
is this is the first one from patreon
this is john griffiths
do you or any family member currently
own a car from a company that no longer
exists
trash examples saturn oldsmobile
whoa hold on wait saturn went under yeah
wildlife really they had it for like
[ __ ] six years in the 90s
wow then really [ __ ] to bed those little
[ __ ] things like they were like
matchbox cars those things hit the
[ __ ] bricks
saturn man how do you get parts for
something like that
i don't know gotta go back in time
that's [ __ ] trash no but they still
make parts for it i guess
yeah what do we got we got a ford
explorer a g there's a jeep
um do they still make the mercury is
mercury still a company
it can't be no no no that all fold they
all like rolled it was mercury
oldsmobile
chevy like they all fall so you're
answering yes to that yeah of course
they stopped making my i've never owned
a car that was in production
ever i had the [ __ ] i had [ __ ] i've
talked about it before i had like three
chevy luminous
vintage models yeah um i know that's a
great question
yeah my family doesn't buy new cars even
though even when they get a little bit
of cage they've never my mom just got
her first new car
yeah ever what'd she get like a [ __ ]
mercury uh she got like a
chevy traverse that's why you got a
lease baby you lease your [ __ ] leash
you get a brand new car every three
years doesn't matter what you do to it
elise yeah but i feel like you're paying
way more money there's
there's a reason they want you to lease
the car and your fat [ __ ]
family's waiting out front the driving
sign event just [ __ ]
taking them out they're [ __ ] pulling
any car every three weeks pulling a new
car off the lot
driving sign of it oh man that's [ __ ]
trash that's a trash can did you ever go
to the
actual like the dealership with your
father
because my dad was a [ __ ] master at
[ __ ] beating up guys and getting a
[ __ ] good deal
it was always fun to go with him to the
car dealership on like a saturday when
he was looking at a new car
no i i went one time with with my with
my step-dad who was like for majin right
he's like he's gotta he doesn't like
talking to anybody he definitely doesn't
like spending money
and he was [ __ ] buying me at cars
before i got to teego
and uh he we walked in and the guy
called me
uh we sit down i had to break like my
steps that we
had to go into like like i went and
picked it out i knew somebody working
there so like
hold on you were getting a car i was
getting a car it was before i got the
t-go
okay the lumina no it was after the loom
i didn't the loom had broken down you
weren't buying a new car no it's buying
a used car
you got to bring your stepdad in for
that you [ __ ] bozo yeah he was
[ __ ] footing the bill for what are
you talking about
where do you think i got the teego was
it one of those wait first of all you're
breaking my balls you're 44 and you're
driving your parents car
that's not true i paid for my car what
are you talking about it ain't in your
name cut the cameras
it ain't in your name it ain't in my
name yeah for legal purposes yes same
with me
i ain't got no money legally i can't
afford it
i got warrants out there huh um yes
i mean i was 20 or something like that
was it a used car lot it wasn't like a
dealership
it was a dealership yeah okay yeah cause
there's a couple of used car lockers
i've
gone kicking tires you know what those
scumbags do like on route one especially
i always put like a mustang out front or
something well the competitors go and
slash the tires they with like ice picks
so they can't
sell them and [ __ ] like that yeah yeah
that dude [ __ ]
used car salesmen or [ __ ] real grease
balls
it's like it's just like the [ __ ]
they have like uh a trailer
that's the whole office oh yeah this is
a [ __ ] trailer home
there's like two desks in the corner and
a water cooler you look you know
where the [ __ ] are the keys up front
doing the books
um but we went and like the guy kept
calling me
ryan why because he didn't learn my name
like they told him like oh it's kevin
ryan
or whatever and like the closer was he
kept calling me
like he had the paperwork in front of me
and he's like yeah ryan you know just
say ryan you're going to be out there in
that new car it's going to be nice it's
not your first name it was ryan which
happens a lot
yeah but my stepdad is getting ready to
[ __ ] cut this dude to check because
his [ __ ] name's kevin and i was like
oh god
that was the end of the transaction
because he don't like you either he
don't like me he only did he's gotta
spend [ __ ] money
on me he don't want to know your name no
no but he goes i ain't he we did we
walked
what oh yeah well that's why you never
talk about this car what car were you
gonna get it was a lincoln
see tell the team like a pumpkin
a lincoln what are you matthew
mcconaughey i just got his book by the
way
you're joking no oh man that's awesome
yeah i can read
i listen to a couple interviews about it
he's [ __ ] he's he's aces
uh he's gone though he's crazy i don't
know i like him
i love him coming here in a [ __ ] crop
top in my [ __ ] hair sleep
you read the book all right all right
all
right
welcome back to ru garbage everybody
drinking like [ __ ]
tequila on the rocks or whatever reason
dude that one commercial where he's
sitting out in the middle
in the field drinking scotch yeah wild
turkey or something he does
what a [ __ ] hillbilly lincoln and
wild turkey um
all right lincoln
um i feel like it's probably
one of your cousins does anyone in your
this is from dom furon
okay does anybody tell me does any
do have any family members gotten a a
sports team tattoo
i know you're not a ted we're not you're
one my one cousin
yeah the kid the singer
i think he's got an eagles tat jordan
yeah jordan flaherty
check out jordan friday music everybody
keep it in the [ __ ] family i think
i think he's got a [ __ ] like eagles
calf that i could be wrong
i can't imagine jordan getting a tattoo
i think the foley's
and the flaherty's we're pretty
anti-tattoo we're not tattoo people
yeah i don't think so neither my pipe
yeah
ian has a philly's tattoo ian finance
our friend who's [ __ ]
trash yeah our first guest i don't uh
i don't yeah no one really has tattoos
in my family my dad was gonna get the
fighting irishman
one time is he even a notre dame fan i
don't know see i think that's garbage
because there's a lot of people that do
get the fighting irish guy and they're
not notre name things yeah but like you
have this weird notre dame thing where
it's like you yeah
if you're never they played you can't do
it like shut up
really you have a problem with their
name football see yeah like this is you
know whatever no
i don't love the fact that you think
that hey man don't be using the logo if
you don't support the team
that's trash yeah that's real [ __ ]
trash
oh man um yeah did i tell you when we
went to when i went to the eagles game
with tommy pope a couple weeks ago we
were walking out
and there was a grown man with his kid
like his kid like a 10 or 11 year old
kid just harassing
two like college age uh with
the giants fans and like they were like
yeah whatever man
and like he like wouldn't let it go he
was like trailing them like
like you like like naming specific
things in like the 80s of like
when they played or something like that
i think i just lost uh my audio
no i hear you yeah you can hear me yeah
um was going in that a little bit but
like just [ __ ]
like badgering them like that's a level
of garbage
that's not that's philly too philly's
ultimate especially when it comes to
sporting events
super [ __ ] trash super trashy man um
okay this is from adam k what is the
least amount of money you'll venmo
request someone for
i never request anything i don't like i
can't do the requests yeah i we talk
we talk off air we find yeah i get a
text yeah i don't like
i don't use it though it's tacky to me
especially when someone's like oh just
reque you send a request i'm like oh
yeah
yeah what are you doing merrill
we don't use it that much i mean we use
it sometimes like hey we got to pay this
pay that whatever but we just tell each
other
which by the way this guy's a little
slow with the [ __ ] venmo
payments you like to drag your feet a
little bit your [ __ ] td bank you like
to keep it in your account
accruing interest for it comes into my
pocket what are you talking about
no yeah i gotta send you a couple
reminders everyone well
it's only 12.50 meanwhile i put like
[ __ ] 20 grand into the studio and
you're like
hey man you still owe me that you stole
me [ __ ] 14 for lunch the other day
i'm like yeah you'll get
yeah never do requests that's tacky it's
tacky
it is and i give the kids these days
that credit
okay because you know as a former
[ __ ] server
okay it's you go to [ __ ] a table and
it's [ __ ]
six dudes and they're splitting the
check [ __ ] nine ways
and then they want to do individual
fights
now what happened
but the request is [ __ ] trash yeah
and now there's
do you do cash app that's another thing
you do you don't
don't [ __ ] with it yeah it's it's new
money [ __ ] to me it's the kids i go i'm
venmo right
that's like the [ __ ] yeah that's like
the the
you know the roth trial you know i'm not
doing this [ __ ] new money [ __ ] or
whatever you got going on
cash out what i discovered it sounds
like [ __ ] north korea made it when i
first got venom as you know
i don't know if the the audience knows
this i didn't have a bank account
up until maybe two or three years ago
and then now i'm fully integrated i got
you know a [ __ ] debit card credit
card i got
your mom's name on it that is not uh
where's it right down the barrel
ladies and gentlemen that is not a joke
that's not true i'll show you my wallet
right now
what's in your wallet my mom's
[Laughter]
then when i stumbled across venmo and
realized they had that instant transfer
this is how trashy that's another thing
i'll still pay
i'll pay for the instant transfer i
could have not that i do but i could
have it
i'm not waiting for one to three
business days i might not make it even
if it's for five bucks i'm going
at jg wentworth it's my money and i need
it now but i'll take this 350.
the [ __ ] cheddar number two toby
toby's losing his mind
i don't trust these [ __ ] flybys oh
man
yeah they can close down the cost of
doing business yeah
it's five it's like ten cents it's right
in your bank account
seconds yeah take it out i'll give you a
chunk if you're chugging at fifty
percent daddy
let the kid let his speak oh man
and paypal does it too which i didn't
realize i would love watching that
little circle go around where they show
like a little bank and a little paypal
thing
and they do they should be one more of
me like stuffing cheeseburgers in my
mouth
because i've moved i've moved some uh
figures on paypal that i'm not sure how
legally that's gonna
what the legal ramifications are come
the end of the year for some reason i
feel like
but they cap it at 10 bucks which ain't
bad yeah that's nice
because i feel toby's losing it by the
way
sometimes sometimes i'll leave money in
my venmo
because i feel like that's like a safe
yeah if something's like the couch
cushions you got a couple of bucks
yeah like if something happened like the
heat came down on me for whatever reason
not that there is a reason but i'm just
saying you can be relaxed knowing you
got nine bucks in your venmo
account no but i always feel like they
won't look in there i don't know i don't
know why
yeah oh my god you're the world's worst
[ __ ] spy
ah they got my venmo goddammit they know
my paypal these guys are good
yeah it's the fbi give it your email
address
great question yeah what a [ __ ] great
[ __ ] question
venmo pay request is [ __ ]
it's not even garbage it's a [ __ ]
tacky tacky yeah
don't be doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] you owe
somebody money
you get out in front of it yes yeah yeah
you go out to dinner hey all venmo you
send the text
and plus another thing too i've said
this a couple of times
dude make every single transaction
private
what are we doing i don't want to i
don't care unless i can see a dollar
amount
then know what everybody's dealing in
because when somebody says hey for pizza
and it's 200 bucks why are you reading
it because it automatically comes up i
always have to switch it over to
just my transactions you're telling me
you don't do a little scrolling scroll
to see what people are doing i believe
i'm a moneys guy if they put the if they
put the dollar amount on there
i'm a game show guy yeah and i like the
way i like the [ __ ] price
right yeah i don't give a [ __ ] that you
know like it's some little joke that
[ __ ] tony says to steve
i want to know what a couple of
eggplants or something yeah i don't know
i want to know what they're doing
sure um a lot of my friends will just
say drugs
they'll just put four drugs that's
awesome drugs are great yeah they play
fast and loose
yeah um this is from cracked open which
i believe is a shout out
that's a history hyhino's uh reference
very nice um did you ever i
did you ever collect baseball cards or
any sports cards as a kid in hopes that
they would be worth
something one day if you want to know
how trashy i am foley don't even answer
don't know how trashy i am i was home
probably about i don't know eight weeks
ago
looking through the inventory i got them
in the trunk i put them in the trunk i'm
like i'll skim through this
i got a bunch of nhl cards i'm like
there might be a couple of rounds oh my
god anything i was hemmed up i was in a
bad place with even worse people i
needed
this thing my ears perked up a little
bit a couple a couple days ago on the
news when i heard that the value of
those cards
have spiked a little bit for some reason
i follow garyvee he's a big [ __ ]
arbitrage guy flipping them so i started
poking my nose around
well i was looking for something in my
childhood bedroom my old porno man
shout out to air erotica first first dvd
i ever owned arrow rocket
erotica that's what it was called what
was the plot uh was they were in a tank
what do you mean they weren't
[Laughter]
[ __ ] an attack hey sarge i got a huge
[ __ ] over here
that's terrible i apologize for a
younger viewer you got a cannon in your
pocket
um yeah it was uh you know it was a
couple of stories that tsa guy
you know the pilot someone's voting the
first class lady it's a whole thing
the story's back what was her name chloe
chloe jones or chloe james she was like
a you know
big blonde bombshell yeah nice i was a
nina hartley fan when i was a kid
you would know she sounds old i don't
know who it is
tight little body heart i'll tell you
that tight little body
um what what are you looking for i
forget
i don't know sometimes they just try to
money is what you were looking for yeah
i ended up in your mom's sock drawer and
uh i found like a book of you know cards
and i was like oh [ __ ] maybe
what did you collect was it tops i had
no i never liked baseball
base i never liked baseball as a kid so
i mean i didn't really do that but we
had like hockey
basketball [ __ ] you know this is like
football a couple of football ones
like pro bowl cars i'm like maybe these
or something and i started
i started like typing them in and they
were worth like [ __ ] a nickel and i'm
like
i'm like this isn't even worth worth my
time typing in the [ __ ] names next
thing about your downstairs [ __ ]
price checking the [ __ ] china cabinet
you [ __ ]
scumbag i'll tell you what i did because
we just moved from apartment department
for a while i had this double
i don't know if i if i'm saying this
right like a double eagle dime i had a
dime that was really old
and it was different from oh that's bad
and i looked it up
and i was like this there was like a
thing where like it could be worth a lot
of money
i got a jewel guy ah yeah this is a
double eagle nickel we got here
i'm down in 40 seconds they were buffalo
[ __ ] uncut gems
yeah [ __ ] kevin garnett's gonna beat
you up or whatever
holy man let me get that down um let me
just wear the game tonight
it's my lucky dime i can't do it the
monocle
i lay up the felt yeah the velvet trash
but and i put it i put it you know
because i get it mixed up with all the
other change because we got a huge
change drawer
mostly nickels and pennies you sifted
though you sift through the [ __ ]
hardware on that
quick you saw me doing that when i put
air in the tires the other day
oh all right let's pause this for a
second
i watched the saddest thing ever i can't
put air in my tires
no we almost couldn't physically you
were [ __ ]
huffing and pulling i returned the car
with [ __ ] light tires ma gets made
you know what i mean
he goes he's got it he's got a digital
reader like air pressure
i got a classy automobile yes so he goes
let me know when it gets to 36.
and i was at like 29 i'm like all right
first of all all four of his tires are
low
and he's like i wonder what it is i'm
like it's probably the [ __ ] the head
it's the heavy payload this thing's
pulling around saying a toyota tundra
this is a jeep daddy they say [ __ ]
jade
jd power and associates the other thing
you got a jeep liberty dude you even got
the mini one
yeah it's like a micro machine the thing
where they land the plane in the back of
the pickup truck that's what you got
did you show me parachuting um
i don't know it was i think it was
because it got really cold so my tire
the [ __ ] air went out of my tires but
we were going where were we going we're
going to pick up this table
oh long island and it was raining that
day i didn't want to get out of the
[ __ ]
long island expressway and [ __ ] lunch
hey it took him 45 minutes to fill up
his tires and he cause you have to bend
down to fill it in and he goes
let me know when it he goes honk the
horn when it gets to 35.
so he pulls it in and then he could
never be a catcher
long enough so he's popping up and like
[ __ ] thirty one
is it there yet i'm like i told you i
beat the whole ah it's close enough it's
all right
oh man you [ __ ] it was like one of
those things where like you were
learning to walk and you're like he's
gotta do it on his own i was like he's
gotta learn how to do it on his own
that's funny yeah it was that was a
struggle
oh man you would have thought you were
in a [ __ ] wrestling match
got them pumped up though it was nice
yeah this is not trashy that air
compressor got the best
there but you did have a hard time
digging for [ __ ] quarters
pulling up a couple of french fries and
stuff from under the seat
onion ring a couple of moth sticks got
marinara back here
who had a cold mozzarella stick the
other day it was fantastic [ __ ] gross
smoking like a cigar yeah what do you
say what do you know
it's like a deep red cannoli at that
point
that's not a bad idea i'll tell you what
the predicate always
put a patent on that huh check the time
stamp on this
we got a hot deal going here no um this
is how trashy we were
all right what was the question again
the baseball
from cracked open that's www.patreon.com
dude that's a great question when i was
a kid in the 80s and 90s they were
huge and then when i got into like high
school like they were even
they were even bigger like they were
like sleek and they had the different
holograms some of my holograms yeah yeah
yeah they were really doing it we only
got
my brother every year for his birthday
from she
choked on my whole chipotle uh every
year for my brother's birthday he got
a full deck the full season
of tops for like seven years
now at a certain point you know what i
mean he ain't around no more he's off at
college
i did a little poking around [ __ ]
grifting a couple out
so i got a few rookie cards yeah i got a
few in my in
in my drawer at home so yeah yeah to
answer your question we're trash
because we both i've recently started
kicking the tires on my old [ __ ]
books and you got anything you got
anything of mention in there
nah i had like a couple of i know the
cars park too
grab me a crowbar do a b well i was
gonna
because i knew we were gonna do the
[ __ ] uh you know oh yeah we should
put him in here
oh we could i guess yeah yeah there we
go a couple go missing
i mean dude i found one that was worth
like a dollar 30 it was somebody was
bidding on it for a dollar 37.
oh you got to do that [ __ ] you can't
just take him to i would take him
i think he'd go to a store or something
like that it's like pawn stars are going
to give you 10
of what it's worth they gotta sit on it
for a while you know what i mean they
gotta bring your
expert in they got a card guy let me
bring in a guy who knows what he's
talking about right because i'm some
other [ __ ]
[ __ ] nevada hillbilly i've been
crushing pawn stars by the way
that dude that runs to [ __ ] cook
county or clark county museum
the [ __ ] amish looking dude yeah that
guy knows his [ __ ]
yeah you think they really know they did
do some research on it beforehand hey
i'm coming in with a musket
[ __ ] hit wikipedia for an hour
[ __ ] rick harrison can [ __ ] take a
hike he doesn't
shout out to chum lee jimmy this uh this
is another one this is from chris
great question by the way yeah that was
fantastic uh this is from chris have you
ever had dishes in your car
spoons
i'll tell you this uh when i was at
theater school
we you know we lived in like a farmhouse
together and uh there was a bunch of
people that lived there
and this story changes it's like a new
thing we lived in a shoe
for six weeks and we would take food
into our room and eat it
okay and if we didn't feel like washing
the dishes we would throw them all in a
box
and then drive them somewhere to a
dumpster and just throw them out
[Laughter]
that's insane because they're gonna feel
like doing the dishes
uh i currently have two spoons in my
glove box my [ __ ] wife
i didn't know they were in there i was
looking for a lighter she like gets like
a yogurt or something or you know a
[ __ ] smoothie or something
from the house yeah bringing your
silverware out of the house that seems
trashy
i'm not a [ __ ] i don't [ __ ] co-sign i
didn't know they were in there they had
to be in there for months yeah they were
at the bottom of the center console we
don't that was never that would never
fly at the foley household bringing
[ __ ]
taking the silverware out of the house
who knows where you're going
my mom will pat you down before you
leave yeah where you going
what are you doing with the butter
knives yeah i have two [ __ ] spoons in
my [ __ ]
yeah i it [ __ ] really bothered me
yeah
really bad we also we always had a
couple bent
silver too heroin we would have like a
bent knife because like
you know somebody tried to use it for
something when they didn't feel like a
screwdriver
yeah like we'll have a fork that's like
out of sync a little bit
or the big one was we would uh it
would always be a big tablespoon that
was like bent a little bit
from trying to get uh ice cream out oh
yeah it gets a little wobbly
you need a good scooper yeah you're
going for an ice cold block of briars
that's been sitting there for a couple
of days
that's like [ __ ] chipping through a
glacier you know it was real trashy
speaking of [ __ ] silverware the ones
with the plastic handle
it was like metal but it would have the
[ __ ]
out of here screws on it you ate at
somebody's house with that
you're getting milk for dinner for sure
somebody's got those things they're like
blue they were real thin
yeah i like nice cutlery yeah give me a
[ __ ] give me something i can eat
that's something heavy duty
if a steakhouse yeah mrs stewart why
don't you [ __ ] hit the china cabinet
all right
we got company here tonight yeah they're
like rusting out of the bolts
oh those things stink yeah that's no
good if you got those [ __ ]
yeah they're the they were the cheapest
ones you you could have bought that's
why you got them if you had those you
didn't have the
silverware separator inside your oh man
you just had a drawer full of chaos
oh my god that's my nightmare
that's so good you want to know how
classy my mom is now she's got
two full ones she got two full
dividers like container like in two full
sets really
yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] she's
doing she must be stealing them from the
watering hole
all those dudes coming in and out she
got a lot of people to feed you know
what i mean yeah there you go shout out
to the piece
ah she listens now really shout out to
the piece yeah does she yeah
you're really gonna increase your
chances with her could we talk about
that
what how about how you don't think that
sure yeah sure you don't
you don't in my slender days if we
if we ran into each other at a bar you
don't think that i i would be able
to to coerce her into
something romantic no no dude well like
we talked about you this was like a four
years ago you you had you were oh yeah
yeah yeah
you were probably because i'm older than
kevin i'm ten years older than you
you're probably my size now maybe a
little bigger you're probably like you
looked okay-ish
so i'm probably just 10 years younger
than her roughly 10 or 15.
no you're probably 20 years younger than
her you think so yeah she's in her
mid-60s she's still got it
[Laughter]
i think i could have got her out of the
bar like i said if she was if she was
single obviously
um and she was at a bar with some of her
girlfriends having like
and i said it would have to be like uh
it would have to be like a carabaos or
like you know
like a pf chang's by the mall where like
there was a bar scene
but then there was also dining and they
were in there i told you you go to
michael's
on street road we called it the wrinkle
ranch that's where all the [ __ ] old
broads would go hang out and you'd
[ __ ]
you'd be like 22 get all bombed up a
bunch of old birds drinking melon balls
getting loose on blue hawaiians yeah
[ __ ]
the wrinkle ranch that's the best thing
a lot of [ __ ] mercuries and old
mobiles in that parking lot
i'll tell you that much a couple of
deweys in there
but yeah you wouldn't have a chance i
mean you dress like an idiot you don't
have any money
you're not that fun to be around like
well i don't think what like we would
i would rent a suit or something like i
don't know well i don't understand what
you think you're going to woo her with
you know what i mean like charm
personality a lighter cigarette like a
gentleman
[ __ ] asking the bartender what the
cheapest wine is
you got anything with a screw top back
there
no way no way um that's awesome she
listens though
she doesn't she doesn't she doesn't care
oh see i was kind of using this as like
a forefront to play i knew what you
thought you were doing
listen buddy i got a better chance of
banging your dad and you haven't
[ __ ] get him hopped up on some side
wizards he don't know what's going on
who's that kippy take a run at him
um this
is all time garbage and i have done it
you know quite recently fire away this
is from will campbell
hanging up close while you take a hatch
a hot shower to steam them in a pinch
[Laughter]
dude that is [ __ ] trash you know what
else is real trash when you get hemmed
up
is uh you flick it with some water you
know what i mean you can't get it to
what then you hit it with a hair dryer
it's like you're putting what are you a
prisoner it's like you're putting tin on
a car window
i tell you what's nice though when you
[ __ ] put a little spritz on
you have a spray bottle by the [ __ ]
dryer we had this in our place when we
lived in philly
when i slept next to the dryers yeah you
know i used to sometimes just turn the
dryer on while i fell asleep
it was like white noise to me i loved it
put a pair of shoes in there it sounds
like your parents are fighting you'll go
right to bed
[Laughter]
domestic violence you son of a [ __ ] you
never loved me
that's too funny
at all
yeah for the listener used to sleep in
my basement
first of all we didn't live together you
slept in the basement
it was nice down there there's a big
difference when i was finding a place
together it was nice
and you being in a bad situation and
moving downstairs you had that tile
floor
it was cool in the summer you can hang
meat down there all year round dude that
place was [ __ ]
crisp ah it was cool in the summer
colder than a garage fridge daddy
ah but no when you spray your clothes
you know you have a little water bottle
by the dryer you bring your clothes
throw it in and [ __ ] wrinkle them out
that's nice that's how you got a
that or an iron but i mean who the
[ __ ] iron steaming's kind of trash too
yeah i've hit the bricks with a steamer
you think yeah i don't do it i'm a big
steam guy i can't iron i i've tried
a million times and my mom man she is
something else with that [ __ ] she'll do
it in two seconds
i remember growing up my buddies mom had
the one that you like closed down
what i love lucy it was like
it was like commercial like she's a big
piston would go and [ __ ]
the [ __ ] bell would be she have the
rack that went around
a bunch of people sitting there with a
ticket that would only why did it only
go up a couple of feet i never
understood what do you mean
clothes i always thought that'd be fun
to hang on to and [ __ ] whip up
that was i that petrified me oh i loved
it that was certain
death sometimes they really opened it up
and when they knew it was in the back
something was zipping around there i
never understood the method of that
how they knew what it was how they knew
where it was coming that whole thing was
a [ __ ] mystery to me pretty sure it's
just a
system of numbers one probably one
through a hundred
ah that's garbage yeah that's a [ __ ]
trash move but
sometimes it's just you know what i mean
especially like hotels and [ __ ]
i guess most a lot of hotels might have
irons and [ __ ] but i mean you know
using the ironing board at a hotel is
[ __ ] you're breaking that
do you use would you use the hairdryer
at a hotel i did [ __ ] this weekend
that's my favorite i [ __ ] always
break that out [ __ ] do the balls get
everything nice and dry
i like them too because a lot of them
they have like the zip in [ __ ] cord
because that cord's a real
pain in the [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm a big
hotel guy man i [ __ ] love him i know
it's a nice hotel this weekend
yeah um it's the way to do it for sure
another great question yeah it was great
i love this this is from david scully
have you ever brought a traffic cone
home while walking from a night out
dude who didn't do that when you
do that and stealing stop signs yeah
[ __ ] like that you got a minute work
side in your room
yeah why was that so cool that was so
hard you ever smell them the way they
smell on the inside like that
yeah yeah the cone smell traffic cones
smell awesome i remember one time you
know like the big barrels
you brought one of the with the one with
the flashing lights well we i had i got
my hands on the light through a buddy or
something
i don't know i got my hands on like the
big people that have connections in the
traffic like he had stolen or something
i don't know it ended up and they were
like oh
i had it i ended up in my room and i had
forgotten about it or i don't know what
but that thing must have been on some
sort of timer or something
and i was home alone dude and that
[ __ ] thing starts flattening my whole
upstairs is lighting up dude
it's like [ __ ] it's like contact with
closing count i don't know what's
happening dude i thought they were
coming to get me
you got a [ __ ] stouffer's fb in your
mouth oh yeah i'm sitting there with a
[ __ ] belly full of [ __ ] sniders
pretzels and slim facts yeah being home
alone when you were a kid man
[ __ ] was scary as [ __ ] oh man especially
and i still get a little
i run up the stairs quick i don't like
it yeah i don't like it at all
yeah we used to steal that stuff all the
that was like that was like the coolest
i'll tell you what we had in my
fraternity house in college we had a
[ __ ] actual
traffic light in somebody's room oh real
garbage
dude [ __ ] the glory days
yeah man you should have been god
[Laughter]
sometimes you get out turn it on pull
out the acoustic guitar and just [ __ ]
have us a night a couple of wine coolers
you and your good time buddies oh that
guy
bringing up the guitar shut the [ __ ] up
no one ever did that
as like you know my fraternity was a
little hippie you said every once in a
while you'd have to deal with that
it's just you slowly turn the stereo see
where you get your fashion sense
yeah that's fine that's a that's a
[ __ ] great move though
um you sit there for a couple of days
you look at it you're like damn got my
[ __ ] cone
yeah man for sure it's like the ultimate
rebellion yes you know
in philly people keep them in their car
and [ __ ] they'll pull up and take it
out and like you know use it to like
steal a parking space and [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah
that's a pretty pretty pretty sweet move
too
um number one no what no
tangent tangent tell me that i was
saying i was trying to park the other
day and there was a guy being like you
can't park here and he put a cone there
i'm like dude i will [ __ ] hold you
see
right now get out of here he's like i'm
like
he's like yeah we're doing something i'm
like not you got a sign you got a permit
give me a little give me yes you got a
gun
yeah unless you're a cop take a [ __ ]
hike this is manhattan i'm [ __ ]
taking this parking spot i'm not
bypassing a parking spot
um this one is a no for you and
i don't think so for me this is from
chris have you ever owned any clothes by
south pole
you probably don't even know what it is
do you know what it is tobe yeah i had a
fleece
i had a fleece really yeah i believe so
oh man that's like the ultimate trash
yeah i definitely had a south pole
fleece that was for white dudes who
wanted to be black and shop to k-mart it
had two cigarette burns right here
yeah how they came with them probably no
the fleece fleece is like plastic pretty
much yeah
it melts like plastic yeah so i had
those two little burns in there when i
dropped
a little cherry on myself it's it's all
the
looney tunes shirts from the 90s yeah
yeah yeah
yeah it's real trash it's real [ __ ]
trash i i
the big one all my friends had like you
know [ __ ] baby blue velour south pole
suits and stuff and like
outcast had a clothing brand at one
point that they used to my buddies used
to dress like [ __ ]
you know in sync but like trying to be
tough
yeah yeah i never got into the full
sweatsuits and all that [ __ ]
shawn john and all that stuff yeah a lot
of sean john a lot of [ __ ] echo
oh my god you had a echo came with a
[ __ ]
arrest record i have a pair of echo
sneakers right now i think it's the same
ecco no okay those are orthopedics for
you
[Laughter]
my kangaroo sneaks a little pouch on the
side
um yeah no south pole man but that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] tree
jc panty pennies pennies is trashy
pennies is the trash no i would disagree
with that if you're looking for me
looking for quality it's lower discount
it's loud
the school closed for the kids you go to
jc back it's lower end my mom is
not bradley's no you know what the worst
is that my [ __ ] stepdad loves what
worse
boss oh dude shout out to bosco
now boss comes in when i grew up in
wilkes-barre
boss cops used to throw the big
halloween operation
sounds like a booming town you know how
macy's puts on the thanksgiving day
parade
boss cops would [ __ ] drop the coin
and [ __ ] straighten everybody out for
halloween
you'd show up to boss cops and they'd
get some they'd get some bird up there
dressed up in a witch's costume
and put one on the other side and then
they would send the dummy across so it
looked like a witch street to cross the
street
whoa oh i've seen that old gag before
man that scared the [ __ ] out of me as a
little fat kid
yeah brutal yeah um
yeah no that's uh pascal's just trash
yeah you think so i mean i enjoy it i
think they make a quality product
what are you what are you taking
boscob's money is you biting your
[ __ ] beat
write that check out to paddy foldy
all right um this one you know
all right um this is from ryan portenga
ryan portenga what are they thank you
ryan
well yeah what are the oldest acceptable
ages for a male to ride the following
types of bikes
okay i love this this is fantastic bmx
a 10 speed a mountain bike also
do you agree that is now is do you agree
that it now
seems as though if you're not wearing a
full spandex cyclist outfit while riding
a bicycle you automatically appear to
have your driver's license revoked and
or a recent parole lead
shout out to ryan portanga especially on
like a two-lane highway where there's no
like
you're like almost in the in the
drainage ditch yeah
[ __ ] riding over broken glass and
[ __ ] i think you've got a plastic bag
full of belongings on the handlebars
i think about this a lot because as you
know i hate [ __ ]
cyclists especially living in new york
city i think they're [ __ ] super
entitled they're super dangerous they
cause a lot of [ __ ] problems
i'm sure that's because of my [ __ ]
you know my obesity and all that kind of
stuff
here's the deal what because i'm heavy
and i wouldn't ride a bike
all right okay okay so if that's
[ __ ] up if you live in the suburbs all
right
you can ride your mountain bike on
[ __ ] mountain bike trails no matter
no matter how old you are
okay if you want to be one of those
[ __ ] douche bags in the suburbs
that dress up like [ __ ] lance
armstrong on a sunday
and ride [ __ ] three years around you
know doing this thing and [ __ ] that
thing and all that kind of stuff
dude i see guys wearing those that
cyclist stuff i'm like you
you have to be a [ __ ] dork it can't
help that much
oh dear because i went right and we went
we rented city bikes the [ __ ] tour de
delaware give it a [ __ ] rest man
we rented city bikes tour de bayonn city
bikes sucked too
we rented city bikes and drove down from
all the way uptown all the way downtown
to where soho
did you go drive back up we took uber
back up nice
yeah [ __ ] that downhill is okay that's
not downhill those city bikes are not
easy to ride yeah whatever but i'm
that's what that's what i'm doing
i'm doing it in jeans and a hoodie on a
city bike and i'm keeping up with the
guy in the spandex so i'm like what is
the spandex can't be helping that much
i'm doing the same job in jeans and yeah
[ __ ] idiot yeah that's like the only
thing where you really gotta you go
full in to look but if you see a guy
like what he's saying he's got their
tiny little peepees too
like dude [ __ ] stuffed that thing
would catch me one of those i'll tell
you that
unless i had a couple and put a solo in
there
let him know who's going to roll the
quarters down there um
you see a guy riding a mountain bike
dressed
like in street clothes he yeah he's
going to work he's
he's going to work somewhere he's
wherever he's going he's late yeah he's
got
he's late and he ain't happy he's gotta
he's got someone breathing he's got a
wife or somebody breathing down yeah
his customer service skills are not good
no now
you see a dude a grown man on a [ __ ]
bmx
bike especially if you see somebody in
urban areas
don't [ __ ] with that guy yes because
that guy you're down and out if you're
on a bmx that guy doesn't give a
[ __ ] yeah you see a [ __ ] grown man on
a bmx bike
not at like a [ __ ] skate park or
something like that
steer clear mm-hmm because that guy dude
that dude has borne south pole before
yeah he's in and out of [ __ ] he's in
that joint
yeah yeah steer clear of that
100 yeah fantastic question
yeah i do yeah i'm good um thanks buddy
this is from mike smith sounds like a
[ __ ] fake name but i'll believe it i
like your style mr smith
have you ever noticed this is from my
real name's larry johnson
have you ever gone into a store bar
restaurant to blow up the bathroom with
zero intention of buying anything
what yeah are you kidding me
absolutely yeah i fake you got to be on
the phone type thing oh yeah
you got to act like you've been there
yeah you got to you got to do a spin
move on the [ __ ] hostess
yeah cause sometimes they're dicks
sometimes just go you got a bathroom
like what are we doing here we're all
human
yeah it's either you [ __ ] let me take
a piss or [ __ ] yeah when i was in charge
of [ __ ] like that
i never i would never [ __ ] say like a
normal per if it's a [ __ ] homeless
guy that's [ __ ] stinks
you know he's gonna go in there and [ __ ]
on the walls or something like that he
told him to [ __ ]
keep it moving kick rocks there bozo
yeah but if it's just a person
how can you say for customers only
like what i mean it's a hacky bit too
but 7-eleven
it's like well where are you peeing you
know what i mean 7-eleven don't let you
pee
oh you got to get in with your guy i've
i have ins with
my bodega guys and i use the bathroom
out of bodega
yeah what but if it's in your
neighborhood why do you need it
it might be for nefarious purposes i
don't think that's really to be
discussed publicly
jesus christ but i'm just saying i can
get into my bathroom at 7
11. and a gas station bathroom
yeah i guess that anybody can get into a
[ __ ] gas station bathroom you know
who does
the some of the conveniences do you're
going the bathroom at 7 11.
how many taquitos do you have to buy
them before they let you in
you got to use it tequila hey foley
that's your ten thousand kilo this year
all right give them the key no key walk
right in
right but you got to go behind the you
know when they have this [ __ ] soda
snack do you work at 7-eleven is this
your way of telling me no
yeah of course my [ __ ] [ __ ] of
course
talk to raj all the time hang out
[ __ ] shoot the show you're in there
smoking cigs petting the cat
yeah um all right wait so to answer that
question yes a hundred percent
a hundred percent yes you know where the
best place to go let me give you guys
a little tip especially if you're in a
city
go to a hotel and oh the
[ __ ] lobby bathroom is and they don't
know what's going on
they don't know who you are if it's a
tighter ship they're keen to it but
a lot of times you can you can get in
how would they know they don't
wow this is ridiculous i'm in [ __ ]
room 1088 let me see your key
my wife has it thumb broad
she's shopping right now yeah um
but hotels are [ __ ] nice sometimes
they put them on the second floor to
[ __ ] try to
keep the riff raff out yeah but you walk
up the stairs never go to the elevator
that's where they [ __ ] get you
yeah this is from chris
growing up did your family have multiple
uh remote controls tv dvd player vhs
player sound system and extra points if
the ceiling fan has a remote
we got a remote [ __ ] ceiling fan
right now [ __ ] boop
yeah they my parents right now have four
remotes they have the ceiling fan
they have the remote for the tv the
vibrator
gas powered uh the remote for the tv
the cable remote which does everything
but they don't know
yeah and then remember you remember
universal remotes were big ah
we had to get someone to program them
you're like what the [ __ ] oh yeah
program have someone call nasa to come
on i'm like nah six six nine nine shut
the [ __ ] up but then my dad has a remote
for his chair
which he always thinks is a remote for
the tv and he's sitting there [ __ ]
pressing i mean while he's folded up
he's trying to put the [ __ ] news on
tied up in a pretzel i love him
but yeah but it's it's weird that he
doesn't realize it because
the the chair remote has a [ __ ] has a
cord to it
and he's just sitting there just just
[ __ ] pressing it
yeah um i just kids out to lunch
yeah you know what was bait was really
telling to it
uh having like we had it for a couple of
years the tv remote because you don't
really use the tv remote that much
no it was the cable power all power off
all
the time all along yeah but yeah what's
your save on batteries you have the tv
remotes floating around you know what's
on whatever
but the dog chewed the [ __ ] and we
had like dog bite like teeth
dog teeth marks in it because they got a
[ __ ] hold of it sure it wasn't you
[Laughter]
somebody was sitting in his chair he got
mad really so we had like
yeah we had like it was like gnawed by
the dog a little bit that's garbage
yeah people come over like i don't worry
about that one you know that's garbage
and also
also not having a back on the batteries
real [ __ ] or taped or having it taped on
we were a big back tape oh yeah
my mom didn't know what was going she
was trying to dump her all but she had
work
meanwhile you know what i mean when
you've got scotch tape on there you need
to get new parents because that's why we
were a big scotch
really yeah we were [ __ ] we were
trash i don't know what to tell you
what are you going to do it's the 90s
you can't go out by yourself black
electrical tape
what am i in the union what are you
talking about no scotch tape it's on the
desk
did you have any it was double-sided so
there's like dog hairstyle
did you have any utensils that were like
fire damaged or anything like that like
like a meltdown because oh spatula is
def the spatula
candle definitely my mom still has it
first of all the spatula is
35 years old and it [ __ ] flips it
mean different
dude is it plastic yeah slides right in
there
it's supposed to use metal on metal they
say i know this one is like a cut coat
from like [ __ ]
1972 and i take it you get a hot
dishwasher you could destroy those
things
oh yeah well like the the the handles
all burnt from like laying on the pan
yeah
like a dishwasher exactly we got a
couple of them floating around yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] battle score they're
like [ __ ] veterans
take them down to the va [ __ ] crazy
that's trashy too you know what i did
by stepped i was home you know over the
you know summer you know hanging out uh
just living in my parents house while
they were down the shore
real real garbage but we were grilling
or making some steaks
and my stepdad has like the tongue that
you put in it tells you love them it
tells you the temperature
what it's like like a double forked
sharper image a guy's got a little where
can i get something like that
he's got a couple of bucks on him
sharper image he's got
he's got a [ __ ] steak through my hair
yeah but it tells you like for beef good
chicken good like you put it out it
tells you
that's [ __ ] crazy um and uh i left it
out in the rain overnight and like the
[ __ ] screen got all fogged up and
there was water behind it i just threw
it in the drawer and [ __ ] hit the
bricks
this guy [ __ ] hates your guts [ __ ]
ah he's a good [ __ ]
thorn in his side i told him i'm like
yeah man we you know i left it
we got rained on i left i ordered one on
amazon i hadn't ordered it yet
and i like i ordered on amazon should be
in a couple of days and he goes i don't
even use that thing i'm like oh great
i'll cancel it
hippie save 60 i just bought a pair of
actual
uh metal tongs oh we're big
i feel like [ __ ] anthony bourdain in
there now [ __ ]
what's the place sir la table table sir
what i don't know
yeah it's like this fancy [ __ ]
high-end
kitchen oh like williams and someone
simone yeah but
better than that table the sir when i
walk in
um so we're big into the we got the time
we got the long johns we got the short
ones we're [ __ ] we're
big i'm i'm a big a nice appliance in
the kitchen guys that's a game changer
though because i usually use
i have to use a fork to put bacon or
something
[ __ ] burning your fingers we're
exclusively
okay and i'm making this announcement
now here on the podcast
we are exclusively bacon in the
microwave
from here to four oh my god that's it
it cooks it perfectly no you're trying
dude it's six minutes
it's crispy it's perfect plus there's no
you know there's no mess because i'm
sick six minutes well we moved out of
the oven it's a laziness thing
no it's not it's not better it's better
on the pan no it's not no it's not it is
it's lazy you just said it's no mess and
it's still six minutes
bacon cooks in [ __ ] eight minutes on
the pan so you're saving you're saving
120 seconds
now when you cook it frozen you're
cooking frozen bacon
yeah i'm cooking frozen bacon listen to
me dude you're putting frozen bacon i'm
like
no you're not i am joking you're an
animal comedy podcast i eat it frozen
[Laughter]
like a popsicle yeah put it in a blender
um froth it up a little bit i do have
frozen bacon because my mom
like i told you we talked moms always
have frozen bacon
i know my mom has [ __ ] like [ __ ]
pre-pre-war
dude i we have a [ __ ] bag of raviolis
in my fridge that i don't even
there's no way there's no way
we do we gotta think of stuffed shells
that's i mean
dude they're freezer burnt i mean it's
like ice age
it's like the [ __ ] tundra in there
dude
that's [ __ ] trash oh man we got
nothing better than that we moved them
like i could have thrown them out from
the from the one apartment to the other
and they're still in there man [ __ ]
god baggio listen new york city
apartment you do too much [ __ ] on the
stove top
that's that grease gets everywhere you
don't even realize it
like when you move down to the other
side you're not what are you gonna what
do you think you're gonna turn me to
the you know just letting you know from
here on out okay it's a new day
i want to let everybody know my bacon is
now cooked in the microwave
on a plate okay paper plate
what am i [ __ ] dirt ball no put it
that's what we do
should be a paper plate to absorb the
[ __ ] grease yeah
no i don't want that she [ __ ] take
you take it out don't try to [ __ ] act
like you're
doing you're microwaving your bacon
classic listen dirt bag i am you guys
i would never use a i would never use a
paper plate probably styrofoam
melvin allow me to retort we cut the
bacon in half we put it on a plate
we put it oh you cut it in half there
you go toby he cuts it in half
bite-sized pieces oh my gosh it's like
fun-sized bacon then we have a nice
cover
okay that we put put over it wow that's
my mom uses the dude a microwave cover
you ever check the inside of one of
those things yeah it looks like the
upside down
[ __ ] goodness man you got to clean
that thing those things get
[ __ ] dicey those things are so gross
i won't even
my mom really oh no it helps the cooking
of the
microwaving i'm not my one i don't have
we don't have a microwave
really yeah the [ __ ] europeans don't
like them maybe things will turn around
for you huh
come by you can take a look at mine come
over yes for a test drive
get in there cooking steak i wouldn't
want one either i didn't really want one
either i want a toaster we don't have a
toaster
get a toaster oven that's what's trash
you know i think that's trash
but we're doing our toast in the oven
like [ __ ] [ __ ] and it never
oh my god dude that's like crackhead
status
it never browns it just dries it out
yeah
dude that's [ __ ] you're like you're
[ __ ] reaching your hand in there
you're burning your finger trying to
flip
oh dude listen if you are toasting your
bread in an oven in a full-size oven
yeah you need i'll venmo
send me a vemma request and i'll give
you the 19 bucks for a [ __ ] toaster
that's
crackhead level [ __ ] given i have done
it
hundreds and hundreds of times i
understand i would have to do it now
but it's i mean it's that's a [ __ ]
next level trash
yeah well i'm doing it i want a nice
toaster i love toast
big toast guy um
okay um i'm trying to get off the bread
you know
this is from robert paris is it garbage
to leave clothes in the dryer overnight
what that's the that's the [ __ ]
closet as far as
yeah that and the bed yeah
um yeah well it's tough because you know
we
you gotta fluff it up the next you gotta
you gotta realize that you gotta fluff
it up the next morning you gotta put a
little water in there
fluff it back up shit's gonna be
wrinkled you wanna the thing is you wet
a sock
throw that in there that does it you
take your sock out you [ __ ] run it
under the utility sink
throw it back in there put it on [ __ ]
permanent press wrinkle release for 20
minutes
good luck it's looking like the first
day of school daddy oh yeah
clean as a whistle fresh off the lot one
kind of wet sock though
we usually um we usually use a washcloth
yeah but we did i don't have a [ __ ]
washer and dryer now yeah now but we
don't but like when i was all through
quarantine i was obviously down and uh
down at the shorehouse dude
you people in the burbs it's [ __ ] i
would live out of the live out of the
dryer
it wouldn't even yeah sometimes it would
be like a little bit less i would just
throw it back in the washer with
everything else
run it again
not folding just two t-shirts and a
thing of underwear what is garbage
is leaving the clothes in the washing
machine overnight
because that's yeah it smells like a
swamp you gotta run it again
yeah and you can't escape it it's in the
fibers
smelling like a [ __ ] bar ring yeah
bloody berry mixer yeah you to redo that
[ __ ] yeah it's true yeah you can't leave
[ __ ] in the washing machine overnight
that [ __ ] wouldn't fly in [ __ ] foley
house so my mom would lose it
uh yeah all right let's do one more and
then wrap it up over an hour right
though yeah okay cool
uh this is awesome we love you guys love
these i [ __ ]
love these just us just the fam
sitting here yapping it's nice
yeah um all right this is one you know
wait no we already did one from him i'm
sorry some people
posted multiple [ __ ] uh multiple
questions
let's see here let's set on a good one
this would be for you of sleeping with
your contacts and you've done that i
don't have contacts but
you do that right that's from justin the
p
d patrol my eyes have gotten worse over
i've been sleeping in my contacts since
i was [ __ ] in high school
like literally probably taking them out
three times never caught up to me
never i'd go they'd you're gonna row in
your eyes
everybody would say that to me shout out
but you're talking about [ __ ] give a
[ __ ]
i would scratch my cornea every once in
a while which
kills it's the most searing intense pain
ever yeah i don't know i don't have any
experience with it but
never caught up to me but now when i
went last year that's why i [ __ ] have
to use the readers because my contacts
my prescription got so much stronger
because you know my eyes have been
depleted of so much oxygen
that that my eyes got worse trying out
hearing that so i can't do it now
but yeah for a long time i lived on the
[ __ ] i was out there baby i live on
the [ __ ]
edge yeah yeah where's that where's the
needle now
a whip
great all right this is this is a
[ __ ] big one and this is from
big texas jensen i think it's boy i
think
i think we know him um have you ever or
do you currently display
oh man do you currently display an empty
liquor bottle as a decoration
i gotta tell you i got an empty thing no
whiskey on top of my
fridge right now we gotta get one for
here now yeah i'll bring it in yeah
bring it in
bring it in and eventually we're going
to want you guys yeah we're going to set
up a po box so you guys can send stuff
that you know
yeah we want your guys stuff here too
anything you have that would that would
that would add to the decor
of aunt hoodie's studio but that's an
all-time trash move actually also had a
lamp a kettle one lamp it was a bottle
that they put like a wire they get all
dusty and [ __ ] like that it's so
[ __ ] garbage yeah like a wall of
[ __ ] bud light cans or something i've
done that too
oh my cousins used to collect beer cans
they had a solid collection of beer cans
empty or full full it's not gonna be
worth anything it was empty
well i'm sorry i didn't know you dealt
in [ __ ] old single beers what do you
mean it's not gonna be worth that
strat's a
that's trash mentality i used to collect
what could a can of beer be worth it's
not even worth it's a collection it's
you know you said it's not worth
anything
you know it's either here nor there
okay we used to i used to collect uh
like boogers collect them used to eat
them
i used to collect um how do when like
like when penn state won the national
championship
like a commemorative commemorative mug
or something no commemorative bottle of
pepsi
yeah i had a [ __ ] pepsi from 1988 in
a glass bottle
that had like their their record saving
it for saving it for a [ __ ]
celebration
my cousin gave it to me you just we put
it we put it uh you know it would be
like on display
oh my god those were attractions i don't
know if you remember this this is real
garbage
at like state fairs and like i'm
listening carnivals and stuff like big
state fair guy
they could i don't know what the booth
was but they could take like a glass
bottle
of pepsi they could like heat it up and
stretch it out
and then the sand and twist it and put
the sand dart body
i had a sand art kit i did it myself how
do you stretch the bottle out
you buy the bottles like that i think
they might have i mean we would buy them
twisted like that
no they would this is old world style
they would do it for you right there
like making the caesar salad at the
table
man like somebody would come home at one
of them you'd be staring at it like it
was the [ __ ] taj mahal
yeah we were a big sandor family um i
probably i could probably
go back to my mom's house and we still
have them they're they're in the attic
those are keepers don't try that out
somebody said where's my stand dog
somebody tries to put that on the table
for the yard sale
no no no no no um that you know what
else was
real big on wildwood's boardwalk back in
the day
getting the candle made out of your like
wax hand oh
god that's garbage yeah i had a middle
finger i was like seven i'm like yeah
can i do it my dad's like yeah whatever
i did my middle finger and then they
made the candle the wick of the candle
like
by the tip of my middle finger big [ __ ]
you to everybody i thought i was the
coolest [ __ ] kid
yeah head over to the dunk tank get
called fat by that clown called a
[ __ ] knight
maybe a ride on the go-karts start
crying man that guy called me a fat
piece of [ __ ]
[Laughter]
and he always said my because my brother
especially when he was a kid had big
ears because you look like a cadillac
going down the street with their doors
open
is he killing all dude and fly me to the
dude he was [ __ ] murdering he'd
murder in front of like 400 people
i didn't call it a
[Laughter]
i'd lose it i'd be winging the [ __ ]
balls out and [ __ ] [ __ ]
emotionally missing and stuff like that
because you're doing it okay he's got
you [ __ ]
he's got you shook ah could you imagine
that today calling the kid
that dude he went after
any race ethnicity any physical
deformity
dude he this clown was nuts
and he would smoke [ __ ] ciggies and
drink [ __ ] from a flask
and every time you'd get him he'd come
back up high and dry
now they have the [ __ ] paintball
where you can see we can shoot
they have they have it on coney allen
boardwalk where he's he's
he's like 30 yards back and he pops back
out [ __ ]
you try to hit him the one on the one on
i'm not even [ __ ] around the one on
flywoods boardwalk after 9 11 was shoot
osama
they had a guy in all pads doing this
and just i mean
a [ __ ] lying around the block
of knuckleheads thinking they're [ __ ]
patriots
guys [ __ ] patent baseball bats and
[ __ ] like that that's
[ __ ] trash oh man yeah that's it gang
what a great episode this was so much
fun
thank you so much for tuning in to ru
garbage uh we appreciate everybody
please sign up at patreon.com to get
your questions on the air we're going to
be doing these on a regular basis
uh we have some bonus contents coming
out we appreciate you guys
being uh patient with us as far as that
why we get the studio built while we get
the studio built we thought we'd have a
little more time for the studio but you
know the
the timeline was a little compressed uh
toby mcmullen thank you for all your
hard work you're absolutely fantastic
t-bone we love you guys and we will uh
we'll see you next week if you got
anything else for them as always just
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
subscribe there as well those numbers
are through the [ __ ] roof we
appreciate all the [ __ ] support it's
been amazing
love you gang we'll see you next week